[Musique]
à tarbes
bon ça vous regarde pas je devais avoir
11 ans et est petit ça petit mais
voulait pas mais moi j'ai nathalie lens
ou de giovanni christine mais personne
ne voulait voilà c'est tout c'est ma
vocation d'être journaliste j'avais 8
ans 1972 je me suis jamais cinq ans
lorsque j'ai vu dorothée je me suis
jamais dit que vous avez la télévision
fait moi j'ai rencontré drucker pour
faire un stage pour travailler en prod
et c'est lui qui me reposer de lâcher un
casting pour devenir chroniqueur 2013 je
crois j'ai dû me déguiser dès le 5
janvier dernier
j'ai dit au matin j'étais invité en tant
que experts remédier un tour de la table
c'est pas bien marché donc c'était censé
être en soirée ça s'est transformé
dans sa je vous dis là toi je vous dirai
pas à un peu de censure parfois j'avais
16 ans je devais avoir 16 17 ans 15 16
ans je crois c'était dans un champ de
graminées je suis allergique au pollen
d'une catastrophe apocalyptique
c'était la campagne jeune fille une
campagne armée pour ça que depuis je
regarde d'abord parce que je peux vous
dire que lapointe
pourquoi il n'était pas dans l'air
[Musique]
quelques on sait qu'un montaigne
marchait comme ça dans la rue lui et moi
on s'est dit pourquoi tu ferais pas chez
moi ce que tu fais dans le fauteuil que
j'aime saccomano et ça a démarré comme
ça en fait
robert tu es à l'âge de 12 ans il était
à la campagne chez mes grands parents il
y avait un baron s'est enfilé des verts
de porto ça fait mal ça fait très mal
[Musique]
genre de ma première cuite fume une
cigarette au new york ma grand mère m'a
fait fumer une cigarette quand j'avais 8
ans pour me dégoûter que ça a marché
pour moi je vais rallumer
[Musique]
mais ça c'est la spécialité de matthieu
delormeau tout moment une fois toute
première fois c'est la première fois de
d'autres première fois toute première
fois tu toute première fois première
fois tout premier enfant
[Musique]